good
said france
barely arrived at the grid is already in
the poor youth who
created themselves just denis to think about it I am
shocked added she by putting her hand
on her heart where she had received this
shock it's pau  isn't it madam
françoise to see young people who
care and don't care about life said the
gardener to make it go up
he hadn't talked in vain about not
caring about life but what do you have to
care about  if it's not life the
only gift that the good god
never gives twice alas my god it's
true that they don't care I
saw them in 70 they are no longer afraid of
death  dead in these miserable wars it's
neither more nor less madmen and then they're
not worth the rope to hang them
it's not it's not men
it's lions for françoise the
comparison of a man  an ally she
took declared herself free we
had nothing flattering the rue saint
hildegarde turned too short to be
able to unite we  t heavy and
it was through seven cracks between the two
houses of the avenue de la gare that we
always saw new helmets
running and shining in the sun the
gardener would have liked to know if there
were still many to pass and  he
was thirsty because the sun was
beating down then all of a sudden his daughter rushing as if
from a place to sit was making an exit
reached the corner of the street and after
having braved death 100 times come and
bring us back with a carafe of  contest the
news that they were indeed a thousand
then come without in the summer on the side of
tibéri and may and slip françoise and
the gardener reconcile discussed on
the conduct to be followed in the event of war
you see françoise said the gardener
the revolution would be worth  better because
when war is declared there are only those who
want to leave who live there oh yes at
least I understand that it's more frank
the gardener believed that at the declaration
of war all the railways were stopped
by 10  so that we don't  run away
said françoise and the gardener to they
are smart carine even
and not that the war was a kind of
bad trick that the state tried to play
on the people and that if we had had the means
to do it
it is not a  the only person who
gave him was born françoise à thé to
join my aunt i went back to my
book the servants settled down again
in front of the door to watch the
dust fall and the emotion they had
raised a few had raised
the ex-soldier long after  that the khl
friends had come an unusual stream
of walkers still blackened the
streets of understood and in front of each house
even those where it was not the habit
the servants or even put them at six
and watching festi youn is the only one the
threshold of  'a whimsical dark edging
like that of seaweed and shells
of which a strong marie leaves chalk and
embroidery on the shore after kate she
's gone away except on those days I could
usually on the contrary read quiet
but the interruption and the commentary
which was reported one way by a visit
from swann to the reading that I was
doing of the book of an author quite
new to me bergotte had this
consequence that for a long time it was no
longer  on a wall decorated with
violet flowers in distaff
but are remade completely different in front of the
portal of a Gothic cathedral than
those already detached now the image
of one of the women I dreamed of I had
heard of bergholtz for
the first time by  one of my comrades
older than me and for whom I had
great admiration block hearing me
confess my admiration
for the October night they had
burst out laughing as loud as a
trumpet and told me challenge roof of the
rather low love for the sieur de
musset he is one of the most
harmful coconuts and threatened sinister gross
I must confess moreover that he and
even name him to sin we do everyone in
their there was quite quickly but who has
for him this  that  i am in my opinion the
supreme merit of meaning absolutely
nothing to us it is the white on the ground or not and
the white camille and the daughter of minos
and passive
and they were reported to me in defense
of these two villains by an article  of
my very dear m the father the count
pleasing to the immortal gods
by the way here is a book that I do not have
time to read at the moment which is
recommended it seems by this immense
happiness it holds me has one  says the author
sieur bergotte for a coco of the most
subtle and although he shows
manse times study rather badly explainable
his word is for me a delphic oracle
reads therefore it is lyrical prose and if the
gigantic assembler of rhythm  who
writes bagua goes and the greyhound of man us
said true by apollo you taste racher m
the joys nectar yen of water one
it was in a sarcastic tone that he
asked me to call him dear master
and that he called me that himself but
in reality we took a certain
pleasure in this game  I'm still close to
the age when you think you're shouting what you've
unfortunately had, I can't calm down
by chatting with a block and asking him
for an explanation of the trouble he had thrown
me into, where he had thrown me when  he had
told me that the green leases to me who
expected nothing less than the
revelation of the truth was all the
more beautiful which meant nothing at all
blocks indeed was not invited to the
house
he had to  at first was well received my
grandfather it is true claimed that
each time that I bonded with one of
my comrades more than another and that I
brought him to our house he was always a
Jew which stinks sorry what does not  did
not dislike in principle even if his friend
swan was of Jewish origin if he
had found that it was not
usually among the best that I
also chose when I brought a
new friend they were very rare who did
not  did not give to the god of our fathers of
the Jewess or
to chain fins singing only
natu  really if the lady salam tally
but i was scared my comrade
knew and recovered and not before
singing i'm just going to say i
searched on youtube and it's hard to
find so i don't know
sorry before i get them  to have seen just by
hearing their name which very often there
was nothing particularly
Jewish that he guessed not only
the Jewish origin of those of my friends
that he was indeed the same what they
had sometimes  annoying in
their family and what's his name
your friend who comes this evening from the world
grandfather from the world but I'm suspicious and he was
singing archers keep watch
please without truce and without noise and
after skillfully asking us
a few  more specific questions he
cried to the ace gabes on guard or if
it was the patient himself who had already arrived
who had forced him without his knowledge before
integrating by a
concealed interrogation confessed his origins then
to show us  that they no longer had
any  hey
they were content to watch us
humming imperceptibly from this
timid Israelites
although you keep the spas here or else
paternal song hebron sweet the go or
even yes I am of the chosen race his
little quirks of my grandfather
did not involve any  feeling
malicious towards my
comrades but bloc had displeased my
parents for other reasons
he had started by annoying my father
who, seeing him wet, had told him with
interest but sir bloc
what is the weather like?  'it
rained I don't understand it well the barometer
was excellent he only got
this answer sir I
absolutely cannot tell you if it rained I live
is resolutely outside the accounts
physical agencies that my senses do not
take  no need to
notify me but my poor son he's
stupid your friend told me my father when
block gone how he can't even
tell me the weather but there
is nothing more interesting c  'is a
imbecile
then block had displeased my grandmother
because after lunch as she
said she was a little unwell
he had stifled a sob and wiped away
tears how do you expect him to be
sincere she said to me since he didn't tell me  does
n't know or taste well so he's
crazy indeed he had but when neither
please everyone because having
come to lunch an hour and a half
late and covered in mud instead of
apologizing he said I never let myself
influenced by the disturbances
of the atmosphere nor by the
conventional divisions of time I
very willingly rehabilitate the use of the peep
of opium and the evil christ but I ignore
that of these instruments infinitely more
pernicious and moreover flatly
bourgeois the  watch and umbrella